وقد تم اختبار الجسم المضاد على الأقل
أولاً ثم الاختبار التشخيصي في النهاية
ظهر كلاهما في البداية سلبيًا
صحيحًا ولكن لحسن الحظ د.  قال فارون
الذي كان لدينا في هذا العرض عدة
مرات أنك تعرف ما هو
مريب هنا ، دعني ألقي نظرة
وأخذ صورة بالأشعة السينية للصدر ، ما الذي
وجده ، لذلك قام بالفعل بإجراء فحص بالأشعة المقطعية
واتصل بي على الفور  كنت أنتظر في
سيارتي ، أنت تعرف انتظار النتائج
، واتصل بي على الفور وقال
إننا سوف نعترف لك أنك تعلم
أنه واسع النطاق جدًا ويبدو سيئًا للغاية
وقد صُدمت أعني أنني كنت كما
تعلمون أنني لا أفعل ذلك.  لقد شعرت بهذا الرعب
واستمر في القول كما لو كنت تعرف أن
التصوير المقطعي المحوسب الخاص بك يبدو أسوأ بكثير مما تفعله ، وكنت
في مهب الريح ، أعني أنني كنت متفاجئًا حقًا بما
قاله
لك لو لم يكن لديك هذا
الفحص بالأشعة المقطعية  أعترف أنه أخبرني
بأسوأ سيناريو ممكن أنه كان من
الممكن أن أطلب التنبيب إذا كنت
سأنتظر بضعة أيام
أخرى وأنا مجنون جدًا لسماعه كممرضة وحدة العناية المركزة
تتنفسها لديك بعض
المشكلات في التنفس أخبرني ماذا
كان ذلك كما لو
كنت تعلم أنني لم أستلقي  يجب
أن أتنفس بعمق ، ولكن كلما استيقظت وأتجول
نوعًا ما وأطلب
ذلك ، فأنت تعلم أن تأخذ أنفاسًا أعمق
وأن علي فقط أن أسعل كأنني لا أستطيع أن
أتجول وأفعل كل ما أحتاجه
على مدار اليوم.  فقط
بدون سعال وأخذ أنفاس عميقة
وسأصاب بألم حاد في منطقة واحدة
وهذا هو المكان الذي قالوا فيه إنه موضعي بشكل أساسي
في رئتي ، لذلك هذا
هو الشيء ومرة أخرى ، لقد طرحت هذا الأمر في
لبداية ، فأنت في الرابعة وا
عشرين  سرير المستشفى في الوقت الحالي ، اعتقدت أن هذا
لم يكن من المفترض أن يحدث
لأطفال يبلغون من العمر 24 عامًا ، ما تعلمته أعني
أنه من الجنون أن أشعر أنك تعرفه
كشخص أصغر سناً ويعتقد الجميع أنك
تعرف أننا لا نقهر وأنا تعلم
شخص يتمتع بصحة جيدة إلى حد ما
ولا تعتقد أبدًا أن هذا سيحدث
لك وعليك فقط اتخاذ جميع
الاحتياطات للجميع بغض النظر عن
عمرك ، فمن المهم جدًا
وضع الواقع في جميع أنحاء البلاد في
هذه المشكلة لا توجد خريطة طريق
لا  خطة لبلد الولايات المتحدة.
يبلغ متوسط عدد الحالات الجديدة الآن أكثر من 60.000 حالة يو
يًا ، حيث تم إيقاف 20 ولاية خلال الأسبوع مع أع
ى متوسط إعادة فتح لمدة سبعة أيام مؤقتً
أو في الاتجاه المعاكس في أكثر من نصف جم
ع الولايات ، ألغت فيلادلفيا للتو جميع ا
أحداث الكبيرة حتى نهاية فبراي
2021 وتستمر جنوب فلوري
ا  لتحطيم الأرقام القياسية
، أصبحت ميامي الآن بؤرة
الوباء ، ما رأيناه في ووهان
قبل ستة أشهر ، نحن الآن هناك
معدل الإيجابية في مقاطعة ميامي ديد
التي تمثل ما يقرب من ربع
حالات الولاية ، وهو ما يقرب من 30 بالمائة
تقريبًا من 200 موظف في جاكسون
الصحة ، أكبر نظام مستشفيات في المنطقة ،
يعاني من التأقلم عند 19 شخصًا
يحترم هذا الفيروس ، خاصةً الشباب في
كاليفورنيا ، وضعوا أرقامًا قياسية
جديدة لدخول المستشفيات ودخول وحدة العناية المركزة
مع وصول الغالبية من
مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس في مقاطعة هاريس في
تكساس إلى مستشفيات هيوستن التي
تقترب من زيادة القدرة
المسؤولون يحثون الحاكم على السماح لهم
بإعادة الإقامة في المنزل يأمرون
بالوحدة  نواصل هذا الأمر ونتظاهر
بأن هذه القيود المتزايدة
ستعمل على حل المشكلة كلما طال
الوقت لاستعادة الاختبار
والتأخر الكبير والحصول على هذه
النتائج لا تزال مشكلة بعد مرور أشهر على
الوباء
إذا قمت بمسح ثم حصلت على النتائج
مرة أخرى في سبعة  أيام تعلم أن هذا ليس
مثاليًا وخاصة إذا كنت تعاني من
أعراض 40٪ من الحالات المصابة أو
بدون أعراض وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، فإن
قيصر الاختبارات في البلاد يشجع
بعض الأمريكيين على التراجع في أماكن
مثل أريزونا في تكساس إذا استيقظت
في  في الصباح ، تشعر وكأنك ترغب
في اختبار قد لا تحتاج إلى القيام بذلك بشكل
صحيح ، نحن بحاجة إلى التفكير في أولئك
المعرضين لخطر كبير أو في
المواقف عالية الخطورة ، حيث
تصر الإدارة على
أن التعلم الشخصي يجب أن يكون هو المعيار  على الرغم من
عدم تقديم إستراتيجية ، فإن
البلدان التي تمكنت من إعادة فتح
المدارس بأمان قد فعلت ذلك مع انخفاض
معدلات الإصابة وعدم ارتفاعها في الانتصارات
تتطلب الاختبار  متوفر في كاليفورنيا ،
لا يوجد أي من سان دييغو لوس
أنجلوس وأتلانتا يعلنان عن خطط
لبدء العام عبر الإنترنت حيث أن الاقتراع الجديد من
Axios ويظهر أن معظم الآباء يقولون
إنه سيكون من الخطر إعادة أطفالهم
في الخريف ، روبرت ريدفيلد مدير مركز السيطرة على الأمراض
متفائل.  تعتقد في الواقع
أن غالبية المقاطعات ستفي
بالمعايير بشرط أن يكون لدى المعلمين
الثقة لإعادة فتح المسؤولين
لديهم الثقة في أن يكونوا منفتحين وأن يكون
أولياء الأمور